to be able to bring a smile
or a giggle
it means everything in the world to me
actors do some pretty wild stuff for
their roles but when you've played
characters like johnny depp has well
things can get pretty extreme that was
quite something number one it sounds
appealing until it really doesn't
preparing to bring that wacky captain
jack sparrow to pirates of the caribbean
meant that depp spent a lot of quality
time with his sauna i sat there for as
long as i could until it started to
affect me mentally which is to say it
was very very hot as was my brain you do
what you gotta do the heat was very
important for me
number two trade those pearly whites for
something a bit more dazzling is there
anything more luxurious than gold depth
felt it only made sense for jack sparrow
to have gold teeth and pirates but the
film's producers weren't so into just
how many he wanted until johnny gave
them no choice by having a dentist
implant a bunch of extra gold teeth in
his mouth yeah just sort of went to the
dentist and he bonded him trying to
convince step otherwise would have
resulted in literally pulling teeth
number three it's a bit different when
your character has scissors for hands i
don't think i've ever laughed so much in
my life it was still quite early in
depth's career when he originated the
role of edward scissorhands so he wanted
to commit everything he had which
included wearing his scissor hands
around his house to get a feel for them
i just used to put them on in my house
but it led to some trouble there was a
couple of incidents where i
lanced a few people especially when he
tried to sleep with them on after
slumbering for a bit depp would be
shocked to find that i woke up and the
hands were completely across the room
i'd flung them off during the night at
some point we don't blame him
number four when you agreed to a tim
burton film you're committing to having
anything thrown at you i'm scared to
death
depp reported for work on sleepy hollow
when burton told him he was going to
have an intense horse stunt coming i was
going to be holding on to that being
dragged through the muck and other stuff
for the next two days the fact that the
horses didn't seem to have super great
digestive systems made for a pretty
stressful shoot for dep
number five a full day of work just to
get ready for work that was the reality
when depp was playing in black mass the
actor prioritized looking as much like
the real life person he'd be portraying
which meant a whole lot of prosthetics
and those were far from comfortable with
all that and the makeup combined there
were long days in the makeup chair and
on set but it was worth it for the
flawless transformation number six it
was all work for the character hunter
was a lot of things to me to play a
person like hunter s thompson sometimes
you've really got to immerse yourself so
he invited me to his house that night
depp took residence in thompson's
basement also known as the dungeon which
was full of spiders and a keg of
gunpowder not only did he live in
thompson's house though he lived his
lifestyle this involved a 10 a.m bedtime
7 p.m breakfast with tv watching bar
visiting and endless chats to fill in
all that time
number seven it wasn't swedish sugar in
edward scissorhands depp's character
gets fed with some giant spoonfuls of
stuff but going through filming that 20
times left up puking in the back more
vomiting ensued when the actor had to
run from the police at full speed only
this time he didn't make it to the 20
takes simply disappearing to get sick in
the bushes after running for the sixth
time
number eight they fit him like a glove
literally okay let's set the scene depp
was portraying john dillinger in public
enemies and when he encountered john
dillinger's actual pants well he
couldn't resist but trying them on even
though the real john dillinger had
passed away then he took it all a step
further by actually staying in the same
room that his on-screen character did
creepy munch
number nine losing weight for a role is
nothing new but when the actor is
already pretty slender to begin with
well it's downright dangerous filming 21
jump street depp was already slim but
then he had to lose an extra 25 pounds
for the part and afterwards he was
looking kind of unhealthy i wanted to
get fired
from that show number 10 it's like a
stroke of genius but well awful the
scissor hands surprisingly weren't the
worst part of playing edward
scissorhands since the actor had to deal
with sweating through outrageous heat
just for the sake of his performance
this was in part because depp was so
committed to creating a real and
empathetic character and while he did
accomplish that he also wound up with
stroke
number 11 ready aim fire i felt like it
was being
um
like it was a test in a way while we
can't picture anyone else but johnny
depp in fear and loathing in las vegas
it wasn't always a sure bet hunter s
thompson of course had a pretty big say
in who would be taking on the
instrumental role in fear and loathing
so when thompson was getting to know
depp he decided to see how depp would
feel using a weapon to shoot at a
propane tank with some glycerin on the
outside it's about 2 33 in the morning
so of course i wanted to fire it depp
obliged depp got the roll and a whole
lot of stories to go with it the
explosion was an 80
foot
fireball number 12 but not in a fun way
depp dealt with being dragged along by
horses during sleepy hollow but he
didn't anticipate going through it again
on the lone ranger set the actor took on
a risky stunt himself and while he
wasn't meant to be dragged by the horse
he wound up falling off and got dragged
behind it for a full 25 feet
are you oh my goodness
number 13. a captain is a captain
through and through johnny depp went a
bit off the rails when he agreed to
fully steer the ships when they were
filming pirates it might have seemed
innocent enough but depp was clearly not
super experienced in manning a ship of
this size any chaotic ship movements
that we see in the film were all natural
number 14. chocolate is great unless
you're allergic to it normally filming a
movie called chocola would be a pretty
sick deal but depp wasn't living the
dream since he used to be allergic to
chocolate he ate tons of it on set but
he was constantly spitting it out in a
bucket
number 15. sometimes you've got to go
all in otter thompson is one of the
greatest writers of the 20th century
without question johnny depp was all
about that hunter s thompson life so
it's no surprise that he literally
trusted thompson to just shave his hair
off for the part number 16. sometimes
you've got to switch it up depp was all
about the wacky choices so when filming
tusk he decided it would be a good time
to try out a totally wild accent good
afternoon teaser i am gila point
one that wound up sticking on top of it
the weirdly shaped nose prosthetic he
wore was all depp's idea
number 17 plane flying means some
serious business when filming rum diary
johnny depp was worried he was going to
lose his life when for a few moments the
plane didn't seem to be working leaving
most of the people on board thinking
they were going to crash let's just say
depp was uber relieved to have his feet
on the ground again number 18 he's a
hero in our eyes
okay so he didn't do this for the role
but on set for public enemies he did put
himself in a whole lot of danger by
jumping in front of a bunch of extras to
protect them from getting hit by a rogue
car on set
number 19. man's best friend is a horse
right depp got to know his horse co-star
on the sleepy hollow set pretty well so
when he learned that the horse wasn't
going to get to live much longer he took
it upon himself to buy the horse giving
it a second chance at life
number 20
we're throwing it way back
21 jump street the tv show not the movie
was depp's first major tv role and he
wanted to make a splash often suggesting
all kinds of wacky ideas to the
producers but perhaps the strangest of
all peanut butter the actor offered to
have other actors smearing peanut butter
all over his naked body to mix things up
in the show the producers
weren't smiling ultimately the team
didn't go for it but he was more than
ready to go there
johnny depp has brought some wild
characters to life making for some very
interesting prep processes and practices
which situation do you think would have
been most intense to deal with
you